I want to thank you again for being here
meeting with us and my question is about
the documentary seeing your song I
believe your daughter Gina Belafonte was
very much involved in creating this
documentary and in an interview during
the sundance film festival she said it
was very important to her that she
preserved your legacy and the legacy of
those who worked so closely with you
during the civil rights movement and I
was just wondering if you felt a sense
of responsibility to share with the
world the stories of your peers and
their contributions to the black
movement and other humanitarian causes I
guess it was a responsibility but I
never saw it as a responsibility I
really didn't still don't I sort of a
way of life I don't stop no way how to
do it any other way nobody has ever had
as much fun with a career than I've had
I really mean that and I woke up one day
and I sang a little song that came from
a little village in the mountains you
make Dale day I woke up one day in the
whole world is singing that song and I
walked onto my god everybody's singing
my song now what do I do now what do I
say what do I do with this audience
looks upon me so favorably and all I
could think about was how to lead them
to the things of gave me joy the joy a
diversity the door the joy of each other
I'm not you know I'm not religious so
let's not make any great statements
about by spirituality and or it I
spirituality exists but I service that
in a whole other way than than what the
norm would have you think and I just
think that it was the responsibility as
a way of life and the fact that other
seals if you're responsible for
something it means yet to make of an
effort to go out and do it but it's no
effort for me I didn't lose anything as
method i gained so much its almost Volga
I want said to a friend of mine and
beverly hills at a big house like I
and looked at me and said oh man you
gave up so much you sacrifice so much
for us brother I mean you really did you
just step to the plate and look what
happened I looked around the room for
whom else he could have been talking to
because you what happened what happened
but man you know Korea took a hit you
didn't diss you didn't I said not Korean
took a hit you wake up every morning
talk to your agent and you're always on
the same subject how well did you do at
the box office I wake up every morning I
thought to Nelson Mandela who got
shafted here who got something to hang
on to who got a reward that's odd not
equate able I mean I didn't go look for
mr. Mandela I did write him when he was
in prison I felt that was the thing I
needed to do and to get him out of
prison became just part of what my daily
menu was dealing with injustice later on
thing happened I never expect I never
thought he'd come out of prison I never
thought I'd see him but then I was
rewarded with that moment I looked at in
edison way to spend your life hagen
hagen madiba and he's out here making
noise and make another two wow what a
way to go and somebody say I I weep for
you okay need water but so give us all
you got but ah is somebody not seeing
this in them in the proper context
somebody's not seeing this in the way it
should be perceived I'm havin I'm Adam
thought I'll having fun watch the enemy
retreat bloodlessly